we you know sees you from a bounty
hunter or we put you in a shipping
container where you almost suffocate we
chain you to the floor you defecate on
yourself we put you in cages we threaten
your family we torture you we attach
electrodes to your genitals we hanging
from the ceiling we tell you what you're
never getting out we strip you of due
process and now six years later you're
released do we owe them something I wish
every church and synagogue in this
country was asking parishioners this
question do we owe them something I
think we owe them a great great deal in
the first thing we owe them an apology
and the second thing we owe them is to
dismantle Guantanamo and raze it to the
ground and set up a marker on it like
Yad Vashem and the third thing we owe
them is the reinstatement of the rule of
law in habeas corpus in every single
place that were responsible for people
around the world including her